grand theft auto made its debut on the
original playstation back in 1997
but it wouldn't be until the third
iteration grand theft auto 3 that the
series truly broke out becoming the
household name it is today beyond its
controversies there's a damn good reason
these games became so popular all thanks
to the wild amount of freedom and
creativity the games employed and still
employed to this day
but they need to be ranked because
that's what we do on youtube dammit so
here's grand theft auto games ranked
according to me and eddie mccoo who's
list on gamespot.com i
jacked
my boys
because we're in the same company and we
work together that's called teamwork
[Music]
before rockstar there was dma designs
they made games like lemmings uniracers
body harvest and of course space station
silicon valley which i remember renting
from blockbuster and really enjoying
they also made a little title called
grand theft auto and
it was okay the game received overall
mixed reviews but sold surprisingly well
in the uk becoming a best seller and
while it honestly doesn't live up to any
of the mainstay games after three it did
at least have inklings of what would
make three such a huge success being a
criminal in an open world with the
ability to steal cars and cause general
mayhem
so
here's the thing about grand theft auto
2 it's like grand theft auto 1
but improved
hey you can't say that about every
sequel the visuals and camera system
were both improved and gta 2 added a
multiplayer mode that allowed up to six
people to compete on maps designed
specifically for multiplayer rockstar's
now signature storytelling is absent
from gta 2 as the game is about a
budding young criminal who wants nothing
more than to commit wanton acts of
violence and destruction
which you know isn't all that deep but
sometimes simple works just fine
liberty city stories has a special place
in my heart i know i'm ranking it fairly
low here but we're talking about gta
games the bar is very high you see the
thing about liberty city stories is that
you could use it to break your psp and
go back to an older version where you
could add emulation and homebrew games
in other words the game about being a
criminal and stealing things is the game
that had a major bug allowing you to
break your entire psp system
which i would never ever do and
definitely did not do
ever
my psp was for final fantasy tactics and
half minute hero
outside of that gta liberty city stories
was fine it wasn't fantastic but it was
impressive at the time for just how much
of the gta 3 experience rockstar was
able to fit on a handheld system
that said it also felt like a slightly
watered down version of gta 3. so
good just not as good unless you wanted
to break a psp
2009's gta chinatown wars represented a
departure of sorts for rockstar as the
nintendo ds and later psp game was the
first since vice city stories designed
specifically for portable devices and
with the ds even more specifically
specifically the game made use of the
system's touchscreen and second screen
to offer presentation style and setup no
previous game could
the game takes place once again in
liberty city and puts you into the shoes
of huang li a triad gang member the game
also broke from tradition with its
cel-shaded art style and its top-down
perspective that harkens back to the
original gta
but that was what made it unique and
stand out it didn't try to be a scaled
down portable version of gta but its own
unique thing
a prequel device city vice city stories
debuted in 2006 for psp before coming to
the ps2 the following year set in the
year 1984 two years before vice city the
game follows the story of victor vic
vance and his efforts to develop a
criminal empire and vice city stories
definitely improved on some elements of
the original vice city notably it
infused more personality into the games
the long-awaited follow-up to gta san
andreas 2008's grand theft auto 4 was
beloved by many upon its release for the
ps3 and xbox 360. it ushered in a new
more realistic presentation of liberty
city which was modeled after new york
city let's go bowling
sorry about that
the size and scale of the world was
stunning giving players even more
freedom to explore on a bigger
hang on
yeah it's even annoying as a gag
although imagine if instead of getting
spam calls from scammers it was always
roman calling you to go bowling
anyways gta 4 introduced cover based
mechanics which later saw use in red
dead redemption and gta 5. it also
allowed you as a player to make choices
that would affect the story four also
included a multiplayer mode plus much
beloved dlc in the ballad of gay tony
and the lost and damned
here it is the game that would break new
ground and completely push rockstar into
the limelight gta 3 took the franchise
into a fully 3d world for the first time
and it absolutely blew everyone's minds
while it wasn't the first open city
style game which i like to credit more
so to shenmue gta 3 allowed for an
amount of freedom never before seen
making a city a fully realized sandbox
you could play in and to be honest i
think i spent most of my time playing
with friends so you could get the
highest wander level and avoid the cops
for the longest period of time gta 3
included an astounding for the time
variety of volume and activities to
partake in it had an excellent
soundtrack i can't plan this video
without getting demonetized a fun
original comedy channel called
chatterbox and it marked the franchise's
first foray into using hollywood talent
for voice roles now that gta has existed
for a while it's hard to describe just
how much of an impact gta 3 had and how
revolutionary it felt and the great
thing was this wasn't a one-off and
rockstar was actually able to improve on
it for its subsequent games i get that i
ranked 4 below 3 but i'm also trying to
take into account the insane amount of
impact 3 had and lest i forget gta 3 has
the fine distinction along with doom
mortal kombat and uh
night trap
[Music]
of being a game that also became
politically controversial and a frequent
reference point from parents as to the
evils of violent video games after
playing gta 3 i'd go bike to 31 flavors
and buy a mint chocolate chip milkshake
released just a year after gta 3 2002's
vice city took players back in timed in
1986.
[Music]
his radio also introduced me to flock of
seagulls whose music guy for whatever
reason hadn't heard until then the
game's location was unsurprisingly vice
city which was modeled after miami and
definitely the perfect 80s setting this
time around its narrative included
obvious nods to scarface and the tv
series miami vice
wise rockstar games improved upon the
open world non-linear structure of gta 3
expanding on features and systems in the
earlier releases and introducing new
abilities items and mechanics and maybe
it's just me but i honestly prefer
driving around by city and the overall
aesthetics of it over liberty city
set in the massive open world based on
los angeles it's you
a fictionalized san francisco and las
vegas the game puts you into the role of
carl cj johnson
gta san andreas improved upon entries by
doing away with loading screens between
locations introducing swimming to the
mix a system where you put on weight
when you eat and the need to exercise to
stay trim and for offering what was at
the time a gorgeous world to explore
filled with all manner of activities
grand theft auto 5 the pinnacle of the
series from a design storytelling and
technical perspective amazingly gta 5
was released almost a decade ago in
2013.
yes
we're that old now and yes it's been
nearly 10 years since a gta release
the game's narrative took a unique
approach for the series by featuring
three playable protagonists in michael
trevor and franklin all of whom came
from distinct backgrounds and offered
their own unique perspectives and
gameplay opportunities keeping the
experience fresh the story even managed
to tie together the characters in the
satisfying way by the end yet again said
in a fictionalized version of los
angeles it's you
again
gta 5 dropped players into an expansive
world teaming with life and things to do
places to explore and people to meet the
map was varied meaning there were plenty
of interesting areas to explore
on top of that there's also gta online
and like it or hate it it's still an
optional part of gta 5 meaning if you
like it it's up here with gta 5. if you
hate it you don't have to play and gta 5
was still fantastic as the standalone
single-player experience the games have
traditionally been
and there you have the gta games ranked
if you disagree with our list or hate my
face let me know by instead commenting
about how much we'd all love to see a
gta 6 and
i'll see you guys next time
[Music]
hello
it's roman let's
[Music]
go go
[Music]